- So wait, Nick, it took me,
I don't know how many minutes
my producer can tell me,
it took me not long to
have a "Friends" reference
so I'm just saying, it was such a huge
pop culture impact on all of us.
So, how many minutes into meeting David
did you actually ask a "Friends" question
or mention "Friends" at all?
- I don't know,
I mean we haven't really spoken
about it.
- Oh my gosh,
don't you make me feel like an idiot!
You didn't?
- No, no, no, he-
(laughing)
- I was respecting David's
professional integrity
but I think that-
- Professional integrity,
it was probably one of the
biggest shows ever on TV in life!
- I adore it.
This thing was, I did have to,
I mean David and I are mates now
but I guess in the first instance,
I obviously had to hold
my tongue a hell of a lot
because I grew up watching it.
It's one of my favorite things ever
but I remember, actually I think David,
you mentioned it first because I remember
we were doing an improv thing with Julia,
this was with Julia Davis
which was for a show that never happened
but David come over and we were doing some
improv stuff together
and I remember you in character said,
you left your phone with us
and you in character said,
"I don't want you checking my phone.
"I've got Jennifer Aniston's
number on that phone."
And you said it in
character, and literally,
me and Julia almost fell off our seats.
(laughing)
But other than that,
I don't think we've really spoke about it.
Maybe there was one time
when I was gonna do,
I was possibly considering
doing a play whilst-
- There was one story,
we had a meeting recently
or this year I think on breaking stories
for the second season
- Oh for season two, yeah.
- which we're hopefully gonna
shoot this fall, we'll see,
and Nick was talking about
pitching a story in which
my character got, what was it?
- I think you got like
a fake tan or something
and then you were like-
- Yeah, and I just said
yeah dude, we can't do that.
(laughing)
- But this is the thing,
this is the problem you know,
it's such a successful show
with what, how many episodes?
250 or whatever it was.
- 236, and I hope by now
you've seen them all, Nick.
I mean...
- Oh course, yeah.
- Apparently Nick isn't a fan but I am.
(laughing)
- No I am a fan, I am a fan.
But this is the thing,
it's such an iconic show
that you have to, when you're writing,
trying to like, break story
and do B plots and so on,
you suddenly realize
that "Friends" had done
pretty much everything.
But I remember even,
there was a marketing idea
and I think I remember pitching it to,
not so much like, drinking
the stuff out of the straws,
the kind of, iconic "Friends" thing
but I remember pitching
a marketing idea to you
and I think you said,
"oh, we did it in "Friends,""
or something like that.
- But we hadn't-
- I have a feeling
you might say that a lot.